- [Voiceover] We're asked to
select the correct description.
It looks like all the
descriptions deal with
what is the limit of f
of x as we approach six
from either the right hand side
or from the left hand side,
so let's think about that.
So first let me just
do the left hand side.
So the limit of f of x
as we approach six from
the left hand side,
what is this going to be equal to?
So as we approach from the left hand side
we can see f of four
is a little under two,
f of five looks like it's around three,
f of 5.5 looks like it's a lot higher,
f of 5.75 even is just
going off the charts,
so it looks like this is going unbounded
in the positive direction, so we could say
that this right over here
is positive infinity,
and if we were to think
about the limit of f of x
as we approach six from the right side,
what is this going to be?
Well here, f of seven, it's negative,
f of 7.5 is even more negative,
f of 6.5 is even more negative,
f of 6.1 is way more negative than that,
f of 6.01 would be even
more negative than that.
So it looks like this is unbounded
in the negative direction,
so this is negative infinity.
so let's see which of our
choices match up to that.
so the way they listed
it, they listed the limit
from the right direction
first, so that's this one,
so the limit of f of x as x approaches six
from values greater than six,
we have negative infinity,
so that is these two choices,
these two choices say that,
so we're gonna rule out those two choices.
And then we think about as
we approach six from the left
hand side, we see that we
go to positive infinity,
and that is this choice right over here,
so we rule out that one, and
that is what we will pick.